the school of life pattern
will be
opened in germany there were plenty of reasons for that
because germany invented our favorite word
world pain
and our second favorite word
suicidal
because a single country does not
accidentally or erroneously produce the
greatest philosophers in the world
schopenhauer nietzsche kant
hegel and heidegger were yes  It is no coincidence
that Berlin, where our school of life is
located, is a particularly
livable city in Europe that
is attractive to people from all over the world because we have found
a team of great thinkers and
lecturers and also a
suitable, exceptionally beautiful
location because philosophy
simply sounds better in German  here is a
nice quote from nietzsche no winner
believes in coincidence
this one von schuppen hart also confessed to
us all our evil comes from the fact that
he can't be alone
because the germans have no problem
chatting about big topics that one finds too difficult
elsewhere  abyss
attraction that is as
profound as it is dark because the
germans produced our favorite painter caspar david
friedrich
because the school of life is just a few
steps from the  delicious schnitzel of the
world because berlin is the place
where you can admire our favorite architect
the old purchase by schinkel
because germany is not only or
primarily the country of cars and
high-tech companies but the
country of philosophy,
intellectual debate and the  friendship
visit us at our
new location you will find us in
prenzlauer berg, straße 7 berlin